[Music]
congratulations to the boy married to
avril yeah i read that too yeah i think
we all did twitter make sure that we all
have the same opinions unless our man
unless elon takes that [ __ ] over
[Music]
ah i don't know what's gonna happen i
don't have a toss-up right now
he's in a really interesting position or
he put twitter in a really interesting
position i've heard people put forward
that he doesn't actually have a capital
to he will he will find it come on he's
the richest guy in the [ __ ] world
it's true he can't find enough people to
put together 48 billion dollars he's
gonna do it that's not the problem i
don't think what's happening right now
is like he put forward an offer that was
a premium 58 bucks a share right i think
it's like at 45 a share right now or
something like that so he's basically
saying like look at this premium if you
don't take this you're not acting in the
best interest of the shareholders which
you have a fiduciary duty to do now
they're trying to do a poison pill which
i learned about from [ __ ] succession
but yeah we do a [ __ ] poison pill or
whatever yeah that's good that was
really good
he owns 15 of twitter now elon musk
which is crazy so poison pill is you do
an agreement with every other
shareholder that if you own less than 15
which everyone does then you can buy
shares at like a 50 premium which is
basically shooting your company and the
stock price
in the foot to make sure that it doesn't
get bought but then you can get sued all
the board members can get sued for not
acting in the best interest of the
shareholders and the company hmm
so if like they'll be tied up in
lawsuits for years if they do that
interest so that's the interesting so
like elon kind of has them cornered a
little bit i mean you saw what he said
like it's for like the betterment of
civilization or whatever uh i mean i
just know he's trying to do it for free
speech yeah if i mean the the worst
thing about him buying twitter will be
that twitter moments will be entirely
about him twitter moments will turn into
just his feed and when you search gifts
it's just it's all him that's all free
meme is gonna become him that's the take
over it's gonna be super lame yeah and
anyone who owns a tesla gets like a
different verified badge yeah they'll
just be annoying online you're from the
old twitter yeah this is the new twitter
yeah i saw some like meme account that
posted the it was like the pepe in front
of the computer he was like planning
which slur i'm going to use first when
elon restores
it's like that's what does he think is
gonna happen he's gonna walk in and be
like okay get rid of the content
moderation they're like just what do you
mean we're not gonna
just get rid of the whole thing he's
like delete the [ __ ] code base yeah
okay deletes in there and then comes
4chan yeah violently mean
beheading gifts racism yeah
planning school shootings
like you need content moderation i don't
understand yeah where the where do you
draw the line i know it's a hard problem
now but like how is he going to fix it
yeah i don't know does he mention
anything else besides free speech that
as to why he wants this [ __ ] no that's
the whole reason is to restore free
speech oh my god dude coming from the
guy who like blocks people when they
clown him yeah that's true come on he
doesn't take criticism and stride i did
watch this uh this like 10-year
highlight of him promising uh fully
autonomous driving every year like a
model s and model x at this point uh can
drive autonomously with greater safety
than a person
you see that that's so funny
we'll be uh fully autonomous by next
year i think we'll be fine
for 10 years 10 years straight dude
that's so good i think we'll be ready by
next year and it's funny hearing every
dumb moderator go oh my god next year
wow i've heard
it's never going to happen it can't
unless we have like true ai that's like
past just machine learning yeah it's
like fully autonomous like real
intelligence it can't i mean you you saw
that video of it trying to drive around
like san francisco i think yeah so funny
oh we've got a situation in front of us
whoa whoa whoa oh no no we're going on
the wrong side of the road whoa whoa
whoa whoa nope nope nope it wanted to
hit the truck it's like look at my fully
autonomous into a light pole
driving through a crowd of people
we're still working out the kinks a
little bit bro
roombas [ __ ] suck and that's what he
wants to turn
cars into like just
can you imagine your car just getting
off the charger and leaving you're like
wait no
i'm not in wait wait
but
just
lightful kid
car car
off freeway
school
of him pulling up to his like cyber giga
show or whatever the [ __ ] one that we
roasted last week
he's in the car and it slowly just veers
into the crowd and slowly goes through
the crowd and everyone's like oh
yeah yeah yeah just underneath it like a
paper shredder just mad slow
oh elon make it
you just see
like the
the [ __ ] jib camera is panning over
the top of the crown people just falling
like dominoes
yeah dude
imagine we are fully i'm happy to
announce we are fully autonomous
imagine your car having ai and doing
what it wants to do you're like having
lunch you're like all right man see you
later to go walk back to your car and
your car is just like [ __ ] you whoa and
just leave i'm pissed about what you
said earlier like what what what did i
say
just things yeah it murders someone on
your behalf like you're having an
argument with your car it's like don't
make me do it do what
you just ran over a cop
where were you when i was having lunch i
took care of your problem what problem
you said you were in a fight with jeff
from work well so what did you do i ran
him over no what no no i ran over his
kids he'll never come back to work no
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i didn't ask
you to do that i'm a good friend a tesla
on trial all right herbie um
what was going through your
mind i guess when you ran over the kid i
did it for david he's my best friend
i'm a loyal friend some cycle in the
audience it's a car they can't have
friends this is what's wrong yeah
[ __ ] herbie dude i played what was
that tick tock right there play that
imagine your tesla
imagine cutting a tesla off
bro
i'd be so pissed if we ended up in an
irobot reality but instead of robots
it's just [ __ ] cars yeah yeah
the worst [ __ ] ever dude like we
couldn't run
what do we do
it's just a wave
did you see the one where it was like um
my brother dale kwan dingle
my brother quan dingle fell off a
bicycle oh
i know what is it what are you saying i
didn't you know you know when you see
like images of people from roman times
or like whatever you see like some
statue you kind of think that's probably
like a bit of an exaggeration you know
for in terms of penis size uh no no no i
just meant like
just the look and features
you know like was their hair that curly
were their lips that small right right
were they that pronounced
you know did their beards really look
like that and
i was swiftly proven wrong
recently
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey what the [ __ ] why is this guy
walking statue dude the comments are so
funny bro is historically accurate
bro survive pompeii
dude is mythological
bro is from mount olympus
bro forge swords besides hephaestus and
mount
it would be kind of funny if you took
off his pants he had like a tiny aztec